don't know how to raise children so my
kid came to me and he said Daddy a wheel
came off my toy car and he gave it to me
so I said so it did I threw in the
garbage and I went back to my magazine
and I watched that lower lip guard off I
said what's the matter he said you
throwed it away I saw get your baby toys
where the wheels don't come off
he said well maybe I could fix it so I
gave it on again and he's sitting on the
couch and he gets it together in just a
minute or two gets it together then you
pick my how do you do that it's
wonderful he says I'm not that little
but how did you do it she's just hole in
the wheel yes she's a piece of iron
sticking up I put the hole in a push-ups
I said that's wonderful that you say
here and let Daddy do it let Mommy do
whatever you produce a blob you know
what that means you solve all your kids
problems